taking to see father Noir re's room and
they come across a picture of St Lucy
patron saint of the blind like much of
the lore in the controverse St Lucy is
based on a real person a saint from
Italy in the 200s who devoted herself to
Christianity there are a number of myths
and stories about the cause of her
blindness some versions say that she
gouged out her own eyes when a potential
lover became infatuated with them in
order to prove her dedication to
religion and virginity another take on
the matter tells of how she was captured
by the Roman Emperor Diocesan and her
eyes were gouged out prior to her
execution that seems to be close to the
version of the tale that appears in the
coners she was murdered by pagans they
lit her on fire but she wouldn't burn
before killing her they gouged out her
eyes very metal